one taraj and funeral lasts for several
days and nights
it's open to the public because to
Rajan's believe a crowded funeral is
proof of a life well-lived
it starts out seeming like a County Fair
but it quickly becomes much more intense
there's a buffalo procession a buffalo
fight and ultimately there's a buffalo
slaughter which provides me for the
funeral feast Buffalo are sacred and
they're also expensive with many
funerals running well over forty
thousand dollars in buffalo costs alone
one reason to Rajan's keep their dead at
home is because of how long it can take
to save money for such an epic ceremony
and all of this is watched by hundreds
of international tourists with all these
outsiders I wondered if this was more of
an attraction than a sacred ceremony
I've been confronted by other people's
death since the moment I've arrived
whereas in my own culture in my own
place we don't even talk about death and
when we do talk about death it's very
uncomfortable